good evening everyone I'm sick Gessler
I'm the administrator of the Pulitzer
Prizes I want to welcome you on behalf
of the Pulitzer Prize board and Columbia
Journalism school the Pulitzer Prize is
journalism's highest award and I'm often
to ask how do you win one well tonight
we're going to shed a little light on at
that question tonight we want to find
out how journalists won a Pulitzer Prize
by digging into a story that was just
waiting to be told we have a terrific
panel on my left is our moderator Sheila
Cornell she's the director of the J
schools stabile Center for Investigative
Journalism and my partner in organizing
this seminar she's an investigative
journalist who's known across the world
she began a career in the Philippines in
1982 and made her mark by spotlighting
human rights abuses that toppled the
Marcos regime 1989 she co-founded the
Philippines Center for Investigative
Journalism to promote investigative
reporter reporting and a trained
journalists the center became a highly
trusted news source in the region
reporting on poverty corruption and
political intrigue I've said it before
and I'll say it again if I did something
wrong I would not want Sheila on my
trail in 2006 she joined our faculty and
became the inaugural head of the stabile
Center she's a graduate at the
University of Philippines and the London
School of Economics author or editor of
more than a dozen books and the
recipient of numerous awards including
the highest honor that can be paid to a
Columbia professor she received the
Presidential Teaching Award in 2011 next
to Sheila on my left ear is Sally custon
and John mains there representing the
sun sentinel of south florida the winner
of the pulitzer prize for public service
it's the iconic gold medal
what you see depicted on the screen
winning the prize they told the story of
speeding cops who imperil the community
Sally is an investigative reporter who
previously worked at the Tampa Tribune
in the Sarasota herald-tribune she has
led investigations that found children
missing from Florida's child welfare
agency uncovered fraud in fema disaster
aid and exposed felons working in
daycare centers and nursing homes the
FEMA series by the way was a 2006
Pulitzer finalist in the investigative
reporting category she's a 1987 graduate
at Northwestern University and she's won
a fistful of awards for her work on
Sally's left as John Maine's who's been
a database editor at the Sun Sentinel
for 15 years he's an ace analyst he
played a key role in the papers public
service prize on speeding cops he's a
veteran journalist of 36 years in the
business he joined the sun-sentinel in
1993 as a reporter after working at a
variety of papers from Ithaca New York
to Jackson Mississippi but the
sun-sentinel John has worked with
reporters and projects that include the
2,000 presidential election recount
fraud and waste at FEMA that Pulitzer
Prize finalist I just mentioned and
projects about felons with violent
criminal records who granted were
granted Florida's by granted by Florida
concealed weapon permits he also has won
numerous local state and national awards
next to Sally and John we have Elizabeth
McGowan and Lisa song of inside climate
news they along with a colleague david
has my organs now with us tonight they
are the winners of the national
reporting prize working for a small
online news organization they told the
story of the dilbert dilbit disaster
biggest oil spill you never heard of
Elizabeth has evolved from a general
assignment a feature reporter at daily
newspapers in Wisconsin into an
award-winning energy and environment
writer who values helping people grasp
why these issues are important to their
everyday lives before joining
insideclimate news in spring 2010
Elizabeth covered national environmental
and energy issues in Washington DC as a
correspondent for crane communications
her work has also appeared in a wide
range of publications and won numerous
awards however she says when the
Pulitzer Prize was announced she double
checked the website to make sure it
really happened Lisa song joined
insideclimate news in 2011 where she
reports on oil sands pipeline safety and
natural gas drilling at the age of 26
she's one of the youngest Pulitzer Prize
winners her editor says that when she
was sent first sent west from Boston to
explore the pipeline issues they
wondered if she was old enough to rent a
car she was she previously worked as a
freelancer her articles podcasts and
videos have appeared in high country
news Scientific American and other
publications jazz degrees in
environmental science and science
writing from the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology and by the way this
Dilbert disaster series also want a new
more other very prestigious awards
including the John B Oaks award for
distinguished environmental journalism
next to lisa is john branch and steve
duane asst of the New York Times John
won the feature prize feature writing
prize by telling the story of a deadly
backcountry avalanche his storytelling
was greatly enhanced by Steve and other
multimedia wizards at the New York Times
John joined the new york times in 2005
as a sports reporter and has made a
strong impact two years ago his series
on derek boogaard a
professional hockey player valued for
his brawling shed light in the sports
embrace of potentially brain damaging
violence the series won several awards
and was a finalist for the 2011 Pulitzer
Prize in feature writing a native of
California John previously was a sports
columnist at the fresno bee and worked
at the Colorado Springs Gazette as a
business reporter and sports reporter
has bachelor's degree in business and a
master's in journalism both from the
University of Colorado in Boulder he
says the school is better known as the
Columbia of the Rockies okay steve is
associate managing editor for
visualization at the New York Times
which means he helps run the
award-winning graphics desk this group
consists of about 30 journalists and
designers who research design and
develop the interactive maps data
visualizations and motion graphics for
the times's digital platforms and
printed newspaper it's a department in
constant motion often responding to
breaking news in addition to design work
on long-term projects he's a graduate of
Notre Dame previously worked as a
graphics and web designer at the Chicago
Tribune he started at the Times in 1999
became graphics editor in 2004 and then
associate managing editor in 2013 he's
also been in the Faculty of the School
of Visual Arts in New York City now a
word about our format tonight with
interview style questions Sheila Cornell
will guide panelists through their
stories starting with the sun-sentinel
will devote about 20 minutes to each
prize at the end of each segment Sheila
will turn to the audience for about five
minutes of questions about that segment
only before we move on to the next
segment so please be thinking of
questions from the outset when all three
segments are finished we'll have a
general round of questions please use
the mic in the aisle
nearest you to ask questions we're doing
a video and we want to capture all the
questions anyone tweeting it is hashtag
waiting to be told and everyone
including our panelists please speak
directly into the mics so we get good
sound fidelity and Sheila Cornell take
it away